with each flurry of snow there's another
flurry of cars at Yuri's garage needing
to change to winter tires he has enough
work for six mechanics but can only find
three since the start of the war the
problem just got worse many men have
signed up for military service While
others have left with an estimated 2
million mainly men now called up to
fight technical trades and heavy
Industries in particular are reporting
staff shortages
but all sectors are looking at ways to
fill the posts we see now companies are
investing more and more in training
programs retraining programs companies
are more open to hire people with uh
less experience or students even we also
know that they will be looking towards
people who have retired or are reaching
retirement age Ukraine was already
harnessing the potential of Automation
and artificial intelligence in the
workplace the shortage of workers has
now accelerated that
process Nova posa Ukraine's largest
private delivery company has been
recruiting more women while increasing
the pace of technical
Innovation this is why we are interested
in automating our processes to reduce
the number of employees we need and
increase the productivity of our
existing
Workforce wartime challenges on the
front lines adding to growing problems
on Ukraine's economic front Rob McBride
Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer